All the heroes of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
are gearing up for Avengers: Endgame but one
beloved character seems to be MIA and it’s
not sitting well with fans.
After a massive blast of 32 character posters
for the upcoming crossover event hit the web,
fans immediately took to social media with
one question: where the heck is Korg?
In case you missed it, a bit of background:
when the God of Thunder was tossed into the
Grandmaster's dungeon on the planet Sakaar
early on in 2017's Thor: Ragnarok Korg was
the first to make his acquaintance.
“Allow me to introduce myself.
My name is Korg.
I’m kind of like the leader in here.
I’m made of rocks, as you can see, but don’t
let that intimidate you.”
He's huge, blue, and made of rocks and although
he has a most genial manner, he's something
of a budding revolutionary.
Later in the film, Korg and his companion
Miek join Thor and his team of "Revengers"
in their bid to prevent the destruction of
Asgard, which doesn't go super-well.
When Thor's insanely formidable sister Hela,
the goddess of Death, appears ready to wipe
out Asgard's citizens, the makeshift team
is forced to unleash the demon Surtur, who
lays waste to the realm — and kills Hela
in the process.
As the beast embarks on its rampage, Korg
helpfully provides commentary:
"The damage isn't too bad, as long as the foundations are still strong.
"we can rebuild this place."
“Oof!
Now those foundations are gone.
Sorry."
The Endgame posters trickled out over the
course of a day, and as one-sheets for the
Asgardian warrior Valkyrie and the fallen
trickster god Loki dropped, true believers
waited anxiously for Korg to get his due.
But, alas, it never happened.
It should probably be mentioned that Korg
was portrayed by Thor: Ragnarok director Taika
Waititi, who has been just a little bit busy.
In addition to creating a small screen adaptation
of his 2014 comedy feature What We Do in the
Shadows for FX, Waititi helmed and appeared
in the forthcoming dramedy Jojo Rabbit, and
has been lending his vocal talent to several
episodes of the currently-in-production Disney+
series The Mandalorian.
On top of all this, he's serving as a producer
on the feature We're Wolves, as well as Time
Bandits, a TV adaptation of Terry Gilliam's
classic 1981 film which recently received
a pilot order from Apple's soon-to-debut streaming
service.
With all of this on his plate, Waititi can
perhaps be forgiven for not lobbying too hard
to return as the big blue revolutionary in
Endgame — but that didn't keep fans far
and wide from expressing their disappointment.
Compounding the omission is the fact that
the character's fate was left unclear; while
he was present for the flight of the Asgardians
aboard the Grandmaster's spaceship at Ragnarok's
conclusion, he was nowhere to be seen during
Avengers: Infinity War's brutal opening sequence
aboard that very ship, in which Thanos murders
Heimdall, snaps Loki's neck, and slaps a fully
enraged Hulk around like a rag doll.
This oversight didn't sit well with fans,
many of whom politely suggested that a little
clarification was in order.
There is a bright side to all this: at least
Korg didn't get one of those black-and-white
"dusted" posters, which is more than we can
say for Loki not to mention T'Challa's little
sister Shuri.
Perhaps Korg actually defeats Thanos in Endgame,
which at least one fan suggested on Twitter.
We can almost get on board with this, although
we're not quite sure that trying to kill the
Mad Titan with kindness is really the way
to go.
At any rate, hopefully Marvel will remember
Korg as it brings closure to the arcs of a
ridiculous number of heroes in Avengers: Endgame,.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.